I go from naught to R well mama June has
everybody hooked on following her life
again at this time because of the
incredible amount of weight she is
losing on her new TV show it's really
remarkable the drink has not been easy
and mama June says it's not free either
I have to pee just like your video okay
yeah some people think that I guess the
TV networks and the production command
atria the reality TV mom insisting in a
new radio interview that she paid for
her own surgeries to help transform her
460 pound figure into a size 4 with of
about camera dollar for you to do this
journey um you know no matter what
nevertheless mama June is being paid to
have her weight loss journey documented
for television and her show from not too
hot is bringing in big ratings there you
go trying to put your kids down you can
see mama June also hired a trainer and
changed her diet but going under the
knife played a major role in her
transformation and it didn't come cheap
estimates for a gastric sleeve surgery a
breast lift tummy tuck and skin removal
surgery on the arms and neck add up to
over $50,000 did you wear a fat suit and
prosthetics before the premiere so you
didn't spoil the reveal um definitely
the note over here up at big I was fat
the 37 year old went on to say her main
motivation was getting a revenge body
after breaking up with sugar bear if
sugar bears marriage didn't work out
would you ever consider getting back
together with him I know we're on radio
but he'll to the no and June says her
new look has had an impact on honey boo
boo and the rest of the room would you
encourage them to do the same journey
that you went through it would make them
confident yes I would dad well recommend
a surgery Yoona do your research
definitely
[Music]
you